I didn't know you were going to direct
this or are you hired to write at first
right we were hired to write it and I
loved writing it and knowing I had the
best time writing it we had a wonderful
time doing it it was really joyful and
it was really wonderful making each
other laugh who got the final word
though me I directed it I just love
Margot Robbie so much she's a brilliant
actress and then it just killed me to
think that anybody else would get to
hang out with her so I was like
and everyone cools in this I just know
also Will Ferrell we had on the show as
well I know will is in it yeah oh Isa
Ray hi Barbie Issa Ray simulu hi Barbie
oh yes she got one oh my God I mean it's
Michael Sarah it's oh my gosh
um honestly it was just it was an
absolute dream to make and
um I'm I'm working on it and I would say
just keep the excitement up for next
summer because that's when it's coming
so that's it